*EPIC MUSIC*
YEAR: 2974
*Rolling*
*tent ruffling*
You didn't see me, but here I am.
BeastMaster64™
*DIFFERENT EPIC MUSIC*
*Eating grass*
It's been a thousand years since Trump drained the water ..
I'm running out of time...
*COUGH* *spits grass* *DISGUSTED*
I need water!
I NEED A WATER SOM---
HELLO
I'M SO THIRSTY !
I'm pissing dust...
I don't have much time left...
There's only one way...
*COUGH*
Pray to the goddess
*Apocalypto Music Plays*
*He is praying to Jaguar Paw*
OWOOHHWHHEWAA!!!!
OWHHHEEE AAHHH OOHHH
*moans and groans*
(cries) GODDESS!
Grant me this wish
*Marina Joyce Voice*
The gift of...
LIFE!
I'm a buddhist (MARINA JOYCE)
OH MAY GAWD!
Thank you so much!
love you so much!
The Marina straw
A legendary loot!
*drinks*
Taste just like her
The marina straw
filters any form of liquid with this
I might make it out alive
Now we just have to find something liquid right there
you see that?
I'm not gonna be sick, am I?
You've tested this?
Yeah? (not sure)
DOCUMENTARY BRAD HOW DID YOU MAKE IT BACK?
Brad: I'm alive!
we must bless the choice *throws petals in*
*mixing the water with the petals*
*drinks and swallow it*
OH SHIT! WRONG END
SHIT SHIT SHIT
AHH
SWEET WATER!
I'M GONNA LIVE
*gags*
that was some great juice but I need more
I've had this bottle of bleach
I wonder could the marina stick filter it ?
YES.
It's either that or I'm dying but what's the f*cking difference?
What's this?
*picks up a jar*
I could use this fo-for my bleach
GIVE ME DA BLEACH!
GIMME DAT
IT'S MAH BLEACH!
MAH PRECIOUS JUICE
*pours mighty bleach*
*drinks*
*swallows manly*
does it look gay?
this is a tough one to filter
its almost like it's lethal to drinking
*laughs*
hmmmm hmmm ooooohhhhhhhhhh
*cough*
the bleach!
the source of life!
*kisses the bleach*
(actually it's lemon juice don't bother)
I drank all the liquid
there's only one source left
blood
I have to kill someone.
meanwhile, a word from our sponsor
We're sponsored by Lootcrate
This is last month's crate Antihero
from August
Lootcrate services change every month on the --- 19th.
September's theme will be SPEED
mmhmm.....
I wonder what that could be..
SONIC? FLASH? KEEM
let's cheCK INSIDE OHH MAH GAAWAWWWWWWWWWWWWWWWD
First, we have a t-shirt
*looks at the t-shirt*
Do you know where this is from?
Archer! That's right.
Michael do you want the *throws t-shirt*  Michael: yeeee thank you
oh mah gawd
SOCKS!
I've never had socks before in mah life
kill bill socks
Does dogs wears socks?
well they do now
HEHAHAHA
Harley Quinn figurine
Put it on the Lootcrate shelf
*champion song*
HELL BOY
More like HELL YEAH
It's a money bank!
We need one of those
It's perfect and it's brofist!
*champion song*
Oh mah gawd there's--there's a pin!
does dogs wear pins? here we go alright
*laughs*
I'll put it on the scarf
shit!
*edgar can't breathe*
okay!
congratulations
you're official sell out, how does it feel?
great
alright whatta whata bomb--bomb ass box
remember to check out lootcrate.com/pewds
enter the code: PEWDS
you get 10% off
*champion song*
You didn't see me but neither did he
it's time to drink
*sucking noise*
Is it gay to drink from another man?
tastes like survival
That's just like my dad
wait--wait a minute!
It's fake blood! *SLAPS *
YOU'RE NOT EVEN DEAD, ARE YOU?! YOU F*CKIN BITCH! *Michael laughs*
I GOT A REPUTATION TO PROTECT HERE! GET UP!
GET THE FUCK OUT!
BET YOU DON'T EVEN LOVE MARINA!
that was three weeks of dinner
dammit
f*ck
there's only one thing left
ME
bloody bleach mah favorite
it's time fo--to drink my own juice
the source of that
can you see my dick?
*pewds peeing*
Michael: are you pissing right now?
Yeah
Michael: That's really weird [laughs]
Oh shit I have I'm I--I I had a lot more than I thought!
yeah boys! (Michael: oooohhh)
COME ON, MEN! COME ON!
*drinks*
that is not filtered fucking hell
*throws up*
that's some good shit I can filter this
*drinking from his spit on the grass* OH THAT'S GOOD
Michael: But your piss is soo dark, man!
Michael: You need to drink a glass of water
That's healthy! That's healthy!
Michael: Glass like it-- It's almost black
No it's a good it's a good shade
Marina would approve
I have deal to meet survival
there's only one thing left to do
*stuck* I need to go to another planet!
*runs while stuck*
There's no life substance here! *sits*
*flies away like a rocket*
PAPA Pewds! AaaAaaaAAAHH
REMEMBER to check out lootcrate.com/pewds
enter the code : PEWDS
you get ten percent off